most of the storylines we've been
discussing over the past few weeks for
the 2019 season focus on things that we
won't know about until the regular
season begins story number 13 focuses on
something that should be resolved before
week one and that is the status of
chiefs receiver tyree kill he agreed to
leave the team's offseason program the
same night that a very troubling audio
emerged that was the first night of the
draft since then he hasn't been with the
team the thinking is he'll be back in
time for training camp but what kind of
a suspension if any will be imposed upon
him when the regular season begins
that's for the commissioner to determine
and a couple of things to keep in mind
here you can indeed be suspended under
the personal conduct policy despite
evidence of any type of violence being
committed last year jimmy smith ravens
cornerback was suspended four games for
making threats and engaging in emotional
abuse of the mother of his child here we
know tyreek hill's history with crystal
espinal he admitted to choking and
beating her when she was pregnant in
2014
these threats that were made in that
audio you need to be terrified of me too
chilling on the surface and also maybe
enough to get him suspended four games
to start the season there could be more
based upon what the nfl has found in its
investigation we won't know until the
commissioner makes a decision and the
commissioner rarely shares ahead of time
what he's planning to do and one thing
i've noticed since the ezekiel elliott
case from two years ago the commissioner
seems to be more willing to find ways to
keep players on the field if they
haven't been arrested or charged and
hill in this instance has not been
arrested or charged the nfl understands
the game is more compelling when the
best players play and if tyree kill is
going to be suspended there will be a
period of games where the best players
aren't playing that is a real world
business factor that factors into what
ultimately will happen with tyree kill
either way what the commissioner decides
and when he decides at one of the
biggest stories in the nfl as the 2019
season approaches
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports